welcome to the class of genetic
engineering and biotechnology I'm Mike
Schneider professor and chair of
genetics in this class we're gonna learn
about three topics we're going to learn
about methods for genetically
engineering organisms we're going to
learn about their applications of
biotechnology and we're gonna learn
basic principles about drugs and their
development
we're gonna learn all about the methods
the history and the current ones for
manipulating organisms to all sorts
microorganisms yeast plants animals and
even humans we're gonna learn about how
genetic engineering is dramatically
changing biotechnology and
revolutionising industry we're gonna
cover the basic types of drugs and how
they're developed we're gonna even talk
a little bit about regulation of drugs
and their various methods of drug
discovery overall it's going to be an
exciting class we hope you're really
gonna enjoy it